aruro Nava is fresh off a flight from
Mexico City ready to start a new life in
Canada the petrochemical engineer
traveled on a tourist visa but as soon
as he landed at Montreal's Trudeau
airport he requested Refugee
status Mex he says there's a lot of talk
in Mexico about how supportive Canada is
to refugees though he admits he didn't
have much information about what the
process
entails
Nava is one of thousands of Mexicans who
are coming to Quebec to claim Refugee
status in 2023 Quebec processed more
than 25,000 Asylum claims at the airport
more than double the amount of 2022 in
general Asylum requests in Quebec have
exploded in the past 2 years in 2021
Quebec received a total of just over
10,000 requests compared to more than
59,000 in 2023 in 21 there were more
than 1300 requests from Mexican citizens
in 2023 the government received more
than 15,000 requests a high number of
people with Haitian and Colombian
citizenship also requested Refugee
status in the province those who land at
Trudeau airport and have nowhere to stay
are sent here the regional program for
settlement and integration of Asylum
Seekers known as prid Elizabeth Valencia
says it has been harder than she thought
much
a few blocks away from Pride us shelter
is the welcome Collective they say
they've seen an increase of Asylum
Seekers like Nava and Valencia coming
through the airport a major issue is
that their work permits don't come right
away pushing many to request financial
assistance for the first 15 days of 2024
Quebec's labor Ministry says there have
been nearly 10,000 requests that's an
average of 656 per day an estimated 30%
come from Asylum Seekers Melissa CL says
the government should issue work permits
upon arrival just like it did for
Ukrainian refugees that's going to mean
that so many families thousands of
families won't have to go on welfare in
the first place federally funded
assistance would also help she says to
navigate a massive change and the
reality of a new and unknown
life Gloria Enriquez Global News
Montreal